-Welcome to the "Tonight Show,"
everybody.
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-- at home.
Well guys, this afternoon,
President Biden
held a press conference to
mark his first year in office.
And this was smart.
To make Biden look good,
they had the CDC Director
go out first and open for him.
[ Laughter ]
"Boo, yeah! okay."
The press conference kicked off
at 4:00 p.m.
You can tell it was really
important for Biden,
because that's right in
the middle of dinner.
[ Laughter ]
4:00 is when
I put my jammies on.
Yeah, it was his first formal
press conference
at the White House since
March of last year.
In Biden's defense, that one
just wrapped up a few days ago.
[ Laughter ]
"I had an old friend named
three-toed Larry."
[ Laughter ]
"He had a big toe, a middle toe,
and another big toe."
[ Laughter ]
In his speech, Biden says that
we're in a better place
with COVID than
we've been before.
Then a reporter sneezed
and everyone hit the floor.
[ Laughter ]
Biden also said, "Should we have
done more testing earlier?
Yes, but we're doing more now."
And he spent the next hour
asking himself questions until
the press conference was over.
[ Laughter ]
"Is the economy rebounding?
Yeah.
Did I see the new Spider-Man?
No.
Do I like superhero movies?
Yeah."
But here's some good news.
Madame Tussauds just unveiled
their new figure
of President Biden.
Take a look at this.
[ Audience oohs ]
Weirdly enough, that wax statue
has a 60% approval rating.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
-Some more news, I saw that the
January 6th committee
just issued subpoenas
to a few more of Trump's
former associates, including
his old lawyer, Rudy Giuliani.
You could tell Rudy is not a
very good lawyer,
because the first thing he
did he was google,
"What is a subpoena?"
[ Laughter ]
Rudy said he'd only comply if
his lawyer was present.
Then he put a sock over his hand
and said,
"I'm Mr. Giuliani's counsel."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, if you google
Giuliani's subpoena,
they show you a clip from
the "Borat" movie.
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
-Some TV news.
PBS just announced that
"Arthur,"
the longest-running animated
kids show in history,
will end next month
with a four --
[ Audience "aws" ]
with a four-part finale
that shows the characters as
grown-ups.
Yeah, aardvarks only live about
20 years,
so this could get kind of heavy.
[ Laughter ]
Here's Arthur as a kid.
Yeah.
And here he is as grown-Up.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's interesting.
So this is going to be cute.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Well listen to this,
the CEO of Airbnb said that
he's going to permanently live
in Airbnb properties
and move to a new one
every two weeks.
Yeah. The CEO of motel 6 heard
this idea and was like,
"Do not expect that from me."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, I read that Peloton
is reportedly considering
scaling back
and closing some stores.
We're three weeks into January,
I didn't expect my bike
to be the one giving up.